5 44 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we have an update
for you on school zone
flashing lights so the city of las vegas
says it's been talking with the ccsd
and ccsd has confirmed to the city's
public works team
that with no students in classrooms in
the first semester that starts august
24th
no school zone flashing lights will be
activated at all
except for campuses they're going to be
used as those food
distribution sites now as for those
private and charter schools within the
city of las vegas
that also have their own school zone
flashing lights the city says
it's working to make sure they always
have the most up-to-date information
they note
we are able to activate or deactivate
each system remotely
and they say we can make adjustments
immediately if or when a school's
situation
changes and you know how we learned
earlier this year that each city within
the county
controls the school zone lights within
their boundaries well we'll update you
with henderson and north lawson for
north las vegas from information before
the school year starts
in the meantime please buckle up drive
carefully and put down that phone
we love to get your emails if there's
something driving you crazy and please
include
photos and videos when you send it to
traffic eight at eight news now dot com